tatsächlich es steht ja die
anschuldigung im raum dass dieser fehler
dadurch entstanden sein könnte weil
facebook den profit tatsächlich überall
im gestellt hat die frage die sich da
jetzt stellt welche potenziellen folgen
könnte das wenn es so sein sollte haben
für mark zuckerberg für sein image und
aber auch für die wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen die dann davon getragen
werden können ja also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das so ist es
super gering also was ähnliches schon
mal im märz 2009 10 passiert da war
facebook und alle anderen services
ungefähr 14 stunden offline am ende hat
facebook dann eine kurze erklärung
gegeben es hat aber nix auch irgendwie
absichtliche hacker versuche hingewiesen
ich denke die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
das der fall ist dass da irgendjemand
versucht er schaden anzurichten ist
relativ gering was dort passiert das ist
schon häufig an der geschichte passiert
im endeffekt ist es so dass facebook
quasi wie aus dem internet gelöscht
wurde über die dns das ist wie so ein
telefonbuch wo wenn man facebook.com im
internet eingibt zum beispiel das dann
zur richtigen ip adresse weitergeleitet
wird und da passieren ab und zu fehler
und jetzt hat facebook natürlich eine
ganz große herausforderung weil nicht
nur die services die wir kennen sind
letztendlich betroffen sondern auch die
internen systeme von facebook sind
betroffen das bedeutet die e-mails von
facebook mitarbeitern die interne
kommunikationssysteme von facebook
mitarbeitern und sodann zu kooperieren
um eine lösung zu finden ist schwierig
und deshalb dauerte eine weile aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es sich hier um
einen angriff handelt halte ich derzeit
für recht gering sie arbeiten ja für das
unternehmen wie fox inwiefern betrifft
sie das und er unternehmen aktuell und
wie hat sie das auch persönlich heute
abend erreicht wie sind sie damit
umgegangen
ja also ich meine wo es natürlich
jemanden beeinflusst für uns ist in der
kommunikation mit
investoren
mit mitarbeitern und die kommunikation
ist halt viel langsamer und es hat
keinen großen einfluss aus das natürlich
unsere werbungen die geschaltet sind auf
den plattformen derzeit nicht erreichbar
sind
jetzt nicht
mehr aktionen sind zu langsam und ich
glaube da ist letztlich auch der größte
schaden entstanden denn wenn man sich
mal vorstellen wie viel der business der
geschäftswelt derzeit schon über
facebook und
whatsapp nachrichten gemanagt wird also
letztendlich benutze ich persönlich
whatsapp für deals und business mehr als
e mails und da geht ein gigantischer
wert verloren wenn man sich vorstellt
den ganzen tag steht die business-welt
sozusagen still und experten gehen davon
aus dass es jetzt auch tatsächlich noch
weitere stunden dauern könnte diese
grosse panne
wie wirkt sich das dann tatsächlich auf
das image von facebook whatsapp und
instagram selbst aus könnte es dann sein
dass sie als unternehmer zum beispiel
sagen so in zukunft setze ich auf andere
programme mit denen arbeite ich gar
nicht mehr ja es ist passiert und märz
2009 10 und danach hat sich auch nichts
geändert also wenn das alles wieder
erreichbar ist dann geht alles wieder
ganz normal weiter was sind wir
natürlich gerade merken ist die
unglaubliche abhängigkeit die wir von
einem einzigen unternehmen haben und das
sollte uns allen zu denken geben
ich habe tatsächlich noch eine frage sie
haben angesprochen dass es das ids per
chip oder facebook auch abschließen
könnten was ist denn wenn sie jetzt
gerade aufgrund dieser störung einen
potenziellen deal verpassen könnten sie
das unternehmen facebook dann verklagen
nein auf keinen fall also derzeit ist
die sind die services die facebook
anbietet ja ein unterstützer von uns und
wir werden andere wege finden
letztendlich deal zu machen die
geschwindigkeit ist einfach langsamer
aber auf jeden fall entsteht da keinen
schadensersatzanspruch oder irgendwie
sowas wir haben im vorfeld auch darüber
gesprochen dass das ganze zu einem
umdenken führen könnte sie sagten auch
das zeigt uns wie abhängig tatsächlich
alle von einer einzigen plattform sind
heißt das schlussfolgern dass wenn es
jetzt tatsächlich noch tage andauern
könnte dass das das ende von facebook
und co ist
absolut gar nicht also es zeigt uns
eigentlich eher wie machtvoll sie sind
und wie sehr die welt abhängig ist und
wie gesagt 2009 10 gegen 14 stunden ich
glaube jetzt noch keine 14 stunden
facebook hat es überlebt und facebook
wird auch wieder überleben also von
daher mache ich mir relativ wenig sorgen
um das vermögen von mark zuckerberg
[Musik]